it is 6:00 p.m. here in New York 1:00
a.m. in Istanbul this is a Bloomberg
special report I'm Matt Miller and I'm
mark Crompton armed forces in Turkey say
they are now in control this follows
reports of gunshots near the
presidential palace in Ankara and after
the Turkish Prime Minister said a group
within the military was engaged in an
uprising this comes from an interview
with NTV television there are reports of
military jets flying over the Turkish
capital of Ankara and Istanbul as well
with military vehicles blockading
bridges in both cities and roads media
reports also said ambulances were seen
in front of the Turkish military's
headquarters and at a police academy
there are also reports of Turkish
state-run TV channels being shut down
and then recaptured by military factions
and then going back on air president
Brigitte Irwin says he is still in
charge he is still the president and the
Army's chief he adds he does not believe
the coup backers will succeed president
Erdogan calls it an uprising attempt by
a minority in the army and that they
will pay in his words a heavy price for
this Matt this is having repercussions
as you mentioned we are seeing some
movements in global markets but as we
were mentioning to some of our guests
Turkey's a member of NATO Turkey is a US
ally Turkey has the US has a major
military base in Turkey indeed I believe
Turkey as the second biggest army in
NATO after the u.s. it's a it's a huge
force to be reckoned with
for sure and president air Dewan has
been blaming a parallel structure in the
turkish army for this collapse he is
also saying that he's risked arrest
arrest warrants for those attempting the
coup though doesn't seem that he's been
able to get them to stop locating the
bridges and the roads let's go to sim
endemic on right now she is in Istanbul
Stayman let me ask you about national
media have you been able to check and
see who is in control of the national
television and radio stations there
right now
you know there's so much on stories
right now about exactly who is control
like the military is saying that it's in
control however about half an hour ago
present odds on like on CNN Chuck and he
has been saying he was on FaceTime with
them so we actually got to see him and
he said that will put them in their
sleep as soon as possible myself and the
prime minister will be at the squared he
says it and the coup attempt appears to
be limited to Istanbul and Ankara and
that he is still in charge of the nation
but of course the army is saying that
it's in control so there's a lot of
uncertainty about exactly what's going
on in Turkey right now that sim and I
apologize it's more Crumpton given the
fast pace of these events I was
wondering if at some point within the
prior a few days perhaps even the prior
two weeks if we were getting a sense
that something like this was likely to
happen was there any increased tension
between the elected government and the
military there's no patient to say
however over the past six days president
as one has been uncharacteristically
extremely quiet normally he's on TV
three four times a day you know giving
press conferences talking to the people
talking to the nation but over the past
few days
he's an all-time high perfectly quiet so
even today is speaking about in the
office where it seems like those the
calm before the storm
and that's exactly what taken place all
right Simon thank you so much stand by
we'll get back to you joining us live
from Istanbul John McLaughlin is a
former deputy deputy director of the
Central Intelligence Agency and he joins
us on the phone from Virginia mr.
McLaughlin thank you so much for joining
us here on our special coverage of
Bloomberg Television sir your thoughts
on what is now becoming a situation
where the military and
the elected officials in Turkey are
apparently attempting to wrest control
from one another well you know this is
always a confusing situation when you
have a coup no reports are always very
confusing and what's going on here I
think is that pressures have been
building beneath the surface in Turkey
for years really and they've now burst
into full view in some way are you
hearing me correctly the as some of your
previous guests have noted military
intervention is a long tradition in
Turkey this has happened four times in
the last century three times in a major
way once in a sort of soft way but this
is a very different circumstance today
than the last time that there was a
military intervention everyone or his
party has been in power since 2002 so
that's about 14 years he has really
changed Turkey dramatically it is now
more accepting of Islam Islam after
really decades of fidelity to the
secular emphasis of its founder Kemal
atatürk back in 1923 and he's also gone
through a period of great tension with
the military from which he had mostly
emerged if you look back to the period
around 2011-2012 he was accusing the
military of plotting and he had
something like half of his senior
officer corps in jail they were released
by the court in 2015 in a review of the
case and since then there has been a
kind of rapprochement between the senior
military and air21 which link might link
to one of the confusing elements in all
of us reporting I've seen a report that
the army chief of staff is in detention
somewhere which might suggest again very
confusing situation might suggest that
this coup was being managed or mounted
by
more junior people in part to protest
the rapprochement between the seniors of
the military and their two one
the military's concerns here their beefs
would be multiple first historically
this has been a very secular country it
is no longer as secular as it was and
that's largely are the ones doing and
the military has always regarded that as
their sacred duty to protect the secular
nature of the country second you have
the scuffles of the turmoil underway
with the Kurds now in the context of the
Syrian war and and that raises questions
in the military's mind about general
order in the country third you have the
coup attack and the terrorist attacks
that have occurred in Ankara and in
Istanbul which again create a sense of
disorder the military has always been
dedicated to maintaining order in a
secular nation and that I think is
what's motivating those who are behind
this coup whatever their numbers another
thing that's being very different here I
just want to close off with this and
then if you have any other thoughts you
want to raise another things very
different here is in the past when
there's been a military coup the country
has been very passive in the face of it
because of a general understanding that
the military in the past has been the
guardian of the country period everyone
on the other hand is a very popular
controversial but nonetheless popular
leader and a coup against his government
could turn nastier than in the past so
there could be a lot of business could
get really nasty before it's over
excellent insight John really appreciate
your time John McLaughlin there he is
the former deputy director of the CIA
joining us on the phone from Virginia on
this Friday night